we're 36 days away from the election and
once again all eyes are on pennsylvania
and it's 20
electoral votes in 2016 president donald
trump beat hillary clinton
by less than one percent there according
to the website 538 pennsylvania looks
like the single most
important state of this election
president trump has recently tweeted
several times to what he calls the
suburban housewife
he says they'll be voting for him and
that quote biden will destroy your
neighborhood
and your american dream we met up with
six women from the philadelphia suburbs
at a gym in plymouth meeting
pennsylvania for a socially distant
conversation about that
and other issues hi my name is hannah
and i'm a conservative republican and
one of my main
issues that i'm passionate about is the
pro-life movement my name is melinda
i was a lifelong republican but i did
not vote for trump in 2016
and i am now a democrat my name is
cynthia
i'm a registered republican but i'm
really an
independent i'm likely to vote for biden
hello my name is edith i'm a moderate
democrat
and the most pressing issues for me are
the economy
and the divisiveness in the country hi
my name is mary ellen i was a
long-term democrat committee person i
voted for trump in 2016.
and i plan on voting for trump again my
name is debbie
i am a democrat i was a little
disillusioned with politics but i feel a
little bit better especially since
biden chose harris for his running mate
what was the most important issue that
contributed to your decision
debbie um the fact that i think biden is
more
sensitive towards people's needs and to
the middle class i think trump is
very uh about himself
my community is 100 democrat controlled
and i i feel like i've been dealing with
just lip service people and not
action and i've that's why i've changed
you know my
viewpoint trump seems like the type of
person has let's just do it
we're all affected by the economy i
would like to
get a candidate and a president that
will be able to reign in the pandemic
be able to help us get out of these
difficult times
and i believe that by then will be that
candidate cynthia
i don't like his denial of the magnitude
of the pandemic
and therefore i could not vote for him i
could never vote for
president trump because he has proven to
be
unfit for the presidency he has lied
he has mishandled the pandemic
hannah i feel that
his demeanor hasn't always been
something that i align with but i do
align with his policies
i'm not a big fan of his twitter but i'm
not voting for someone on twitter i'm
voting for
a leader for our country hannah you're
from a military family
president trump was reported to have
said some fairly derogatory
things about people who served including
calling people who died in battle
suckers
what was your response what was your
family's response to that
honestly that's um completely
unacceptable
if it is true then it's deeply
disheartening
said is that going to sway my vote
between these two people
no it's not enough it's not enough let's
talk about the pandemic
how significant has the pandemic
affected your lives
significantly in all all ways did all of
you hear the
audio tape of the president speaking to
bob edwards i would have handled it the
same way i'm not going to panic somebody
you know okay you got a fire going on in
the building i disagree it around and
cry about it don't
definitely stand there grab everybody's
hand follow me
he doesn't have a right to determine how
i'm going to think about it he
hid the truth he did it only for his own
self-benefit
for reelection this sort of thing i am
angry that he did that he
lied again and i don't agree
all politicians lie cynthia he continues
from my perspective to undercut the
scientific community
and i come from the scientific community
i cannot
tolerate that right okay hannah while i
agree
that the pandemic hasn't been handled
completely
perfectly i also know that trump has
given a lot of power to the states
and so the states have made their own
decisions that have been
not so great so i think that
while we really want to blame somebody
i don't think president trump is that
person anytime you have the president of
the united states telling people
to inject themselves with clorox that's
a problem
to me it's an embarrassment to the
united states the way he has handled
this pandemic
and i think we would not have so many
deaths if he had handled it differently
you are as suburban
women among the most desired voters in
the country right now
and are you god
by the way
[Laughter]
so my question is president trump has
made a direct appeal
saying that the democrats are going to
ruin
your neighborhoods no no no you don't
no no no it's i don't take it as a
threat at
all it's just trying to build up fear i
think it's a non-issue
it's none not an issue are any of you
worried about the integrity of this
election
i'm more concerned about the
disenfranchisement of voters
and their votes not being counted so i
can tell you personally
i will not be using the u.s mail to drop
off my ballot
i'll go to a dropbox i've been very
concerned with the president
constantly attacking the male voting
as being fraudulent there was news i've
read
that virginia started early voting and
there were some right-wing people that
showed up and they were taunting the
people in line
well i think if trump does not win
he's going to call it fraud he said well
it's not because of this mail in voting
it's going to be a fraud if i don't win
there's so much
polarization within people i don't think
this election is going to be that fun to
go through but
here for it i can't wait till november
4th is over so
life can start to look a little normal
you know i says
can only watch so many gilmore girls a
little house on the prairie you know to
escape
you know that lady mary ellen mary ellen
wow we asked all the women about the
supreme court nominee and while some are
happy and some are upset they said
it will not have any impact on how
they're voting which they've already
decided
what a great group and you've talked to
them before it's always fascinating to
me to see boater's thought process
and the progression over time we talked
to them at the beginning of the year
four of them anyway
at the beginning of the year i remember
marielle yeah
the construction of the support for
president trump is so interesting it's
like well i don't like his demeanor but
that's not what i'm voting for
you know it's all politicians
construction well the number of these
women have
as as you saw cynthia uh didn't did not
vote for either actually cynthia didn't
vote for hillary clinton or donald trump
she wrote in
another name uh four years ago but she
has decided she's going to vote for
biden this time
wow so there's a progression there um
and uh
a number of these women have progressed
in their views
we talked to them first time i like when
you said your suburban vote is very
important and how they went well
yeah that was lovely that was a great
moment they were feeling the love so to
speak yeah it matters
from both candidates all right